president of Romania his Excellency
Claus Verner
johanes
dear
colleagues dear colleagues we have the
president of Romania K Claus johanes
with us uh today dear president dear
klous welcome to the European Parliament
thank you for accepting our invitation
to address this house as part of our
this is Europe series of debates 17
years of European union membership have
been transformative
for Romania and for Europe it has given
new impetus for businesses for industry
for Science and Academia it has brought
reforms and social benefits it has
brought opportunities for people and
leveled up
communities EU membership has meant
protection for people's rights for
social justice and the rule of law and
in times of geopolitical change these
European vales values must be
defended dear president I would like to
particularly thank you for your
country's unwavering support for Ukraine
and for the Republic of mova
particularly now that EU accession
negotiations have begun thank you to
Romania for always being the champion
the people of those Nations
needed Romania has a a special place uh
in my heart it is a country that has
embraced what it means to be European at
the the height of the pandemic Romanian
doctors flew to hospitals in other
member states to help when we faced
devastating natural disasters Romanian
firefighters left their country to run
into the flames in the first days of the
brutal Russian invasion of Ukraine
Romanian families rushed to the border
to comfort those fleeing so mes Romania
Mr President yours is a country that has
shown how to overcome challenges and how
to lead Europe is stronger thanks to
Romania thanks to your reinforcement of
the eu's Eastern flank and we will be
stronger still when you finally take
your rightful place in the shenen area
and join the Euro Zone in the future and
you will find this house on your side on
that
Journey last word on the nth of June
over 19 million Romanians will be called
upon to choose the 33 members uh of the
European Parliament elected to represent
them we must work together to make sure
people understand why they must vote why
it is important their voice matters for
the European Union and Romania's future
and we must keep listening and keep
delivering dear president dear Claus the
floor is
yours thank you so much
for Madame President of the European
Parliament distinguished members of the
European Parliament ladies and
gentlemen it is an honor to me to be
here today before
you thank you president metsola for
giving me the opportunity to come back
to the heart of European
democracy at the beginning of a crucial
year for the future of the European
Union like five years ago when I spoke
before the European Parliament I'd like
to reassert
the confidence that me and the Romanian
people have in the value of the joint
and solidary European action in the
undeniable Power of One
Europe the effects of the
pandemic the Russian war of aggression
against Ukraine the conflict in the
Middle
East these are but a few of the dramatic
developments which in recent years have
put to the test not just our response
capabilities but also our sincere
attachment to the union and to the
values and the principles that hold us
together ladies and
gentlemen my country is probably one of
the best examples
of eu's power to bring about
change
accession has brought us undeniable and
most concrete
benefits European funds received by
Romania since the moment of accession
have allowed us to carry out essential
infrastructure projects more than
600,000 young ROM Romanian young men and
women have participated in the arasmus
program thus embracing the European way
of
life the union is a space of safety
protection prosperity and
diversity par Excellence the European
Union is an area of free
movement the elimination in March of air
and Maritime border checks must be
naturally and quickly followed by the
elimination of land border
checks only in this manner will we able
to have an accurate and concrete
reflection of of the contribution that
Romania brings to strengthening the
security of the entire European
Union ladies and gentlemen
the European project
needs every day attention effort
patience and honesty if we want to live
free in a United and prosperous Europe
today Romania is a strong
promoter of coordinated joint action in
the spirit of European values it is our
responsibility to support a Europe that
takes forward these principles and
values also in regard to our friends in
the European neighborhood who have
chosen our model of democracy our model
of development and the key moment of
this process is represented by the very
European
elections the priorities that we shall
Define together in the aftermath of
these
elections will come to help us to
provide a prag atic response to the
challenges of the present and better
prepare us for the challenges of the
future our Union faces unprecedented
geostrategic
challenges our future and the future of
the next Generations depend on each and
every decision we are taking
now on a global level the rules-based
International order is being challenged
over and over again Russia pursues its
aggression against
Ukraine around the union instability and
insecurity have reached alarming
levels the open conflict in the Middle
East the situation in the Red Sea and
the wor worrying developments in the
Sahel all these have a systemic impact
on our own
security climate change economic
difficulties and illegal migration
continue to generate their own negative
impact adding to the complexity of
global
Dynamics on top of all these
challenges we witness a crisis of values
and as far as I see it a crisis of
public trust in our
institutions we are indeed facing an
erosion of values within the European
Union which fuels the perception of
decline of Europe or at least of
Europe's leadership and Global
role this is why we need to do more to
promote the feeling and the certainty
that we are are all part of the same
community of values which must be
protected by every single one of
us honorable members of the European
Parliament at such a pivotal moment
fundamental questions lie ahead of us we
must answer them together as Europeans
with vision
courage and
responsibility
first what can we do and have to do as a
union the current challenges are pushing
us towards a
transformative
rethinking of our
actions the past few years proved that
our common action as one as a true Union
is
key our our Unity has been repeatedly
tested and has not
faltered more than this it was a
strategic surprise for some and brought
us tactical advantages we should build
upon
this
second thinking further another another
another crucial question
emerges what can we do more more
internally strengthening our internal
resilience is a fundamental condition
for a stronger Union and for its
increased geopolitical role is perhaps
the most complex discussion it includes
finding the best strategies to respond
to hybrid threats and to increase the
functionality of our Democratic
systems it means developing sectoral
policies such as technology including
artificial intelligence fight fighting
climate change stimulating
competitiveness re industrial production
and sustainable Supply
chains I do believe that the success of
the demarches in these areas depends on
a strong single Market which can provide
solutions to many of the problems we
face in encouraging creativity and large
scale
development we as a union are now taking
unprecedented steps to move away from a
reactive approach in consolidating our
internal resilience we are taking action
in terms of strengthening our internal
capabilities such as infrastructure
green and digital transitions civil
crisis response Energy Efficiency and
Supply
chains
another obvious line of action is to
continue to support
Ukraine we must stand by Ukraine and its
[Applause]
people I have this conviction despite
certain
voices invoking a European solidarity
fatigue defending democracy territorial
integrity and sovereignity as well as
the rules-based international order
cannot be subject to any
fatigue
Romania remains engaged in this common
effort we are strongly involved in
supporting Ukraine as well as the
Republic of mova which is intensely
affected by the crisis in the region we
also need to keep our focus on
security we are now moving towards a
joint long-term planning and increased
convergence in the field of European
security and
defense while
working in full complementarity with
NATO it is indeed High time to deliver
on our European Ambitions when it comes
to our defense
industry esteemed members of the
European
Parliament I wish to express my
appreciation for the strong attachment
to values that this house has always
shown
but we must be aware about the growing
euroskepticism
its adeps May raise issues that are in
some part real but they give wrong and
dangerous solutions that would throw our
societies into crisis it is therefore
our common duty to be honest in our
communication with the European citizens
third how can the union further
externalize its
attractiv
attractiveness
this is another key question to address
when looking towards our future how can
we stay attractive as a
union
the answer is
clear enlarging our European family by
accepting new members will only
strengthen the union the historic
decisions taken by the European Council
last December on the Republic of mova
and Ukraine as well as on Bosnia and
heroina and on Georgia are a victory for
the entire European Union this
Parliament has been strongly supportive
of this objective and I thank you for
this Romania and I personally have
strongly supported and promoted
it
I think that it confirms the Union's
attractiveness at the time of
hardship strengthen its geopolitical
wait and creates opportunities for
member states and candidate countries
alike in
largement is an essential part of our
strategic answer to the geopolitical
developments and a key investment in
lasting peace stability and democracy in
our
neighborhood at the same time the
European Union must assume a leading
global role in preserving the
international order as a precondition
for preserving our way of life and our
values the European
Union's economic
weight must be mirrored by its
International political
role the challenges we are facing are
Global and some of them can only be
solved by promoting relationships with
partners with similar values and
interests ensuring this strategic
network of resilient Partnerships will
make us stronger and more competitive in
the long run this is why we need to
intensify our Global
Outreach towards Africa Asia Pacific and
Latin
America and we do need the further
consolidate the transatlantic link this
is crucial for our
success two last
questions do we have the means to
achieve our
goals and which is the way forward and
what is the future of of the
Union the union has the legal and
institutional inum instruments to
achieve its goals and the response to
the pandemic and the crisis that
followed is
illustrative but it is equally obvious
that we need to streamline our decision
making
capacity we need to closely analyze what
measures can be taken
in a context where some consider that
the real efficiency of decision making
mechanisms is impossible without
reopening the treaties While others
radically rule out this
possibility there is no doubt that
measures such as those discussed in
relation to the qualified majority
voting in specific areas of foreign and
security policy
can be taken without reopening the
treaties without excluding changes to
the treaties at some
point we need to use all available
possibilities under the existing
treaties for smoother and quicker
decision making Romania is fully engaged
in this
exercise honorable members of the
European Parliament despite the views of
some we are stronger now than 5 years
ago we showed remarkable unity in
probably the darest circumstances we had
to face as a
union
nevertheless we have a lot of work ahead
of
us our European con common Construction
is after all work in
progress as stated by jacqu delore the
Visionary European leader that whom we
recently paid homage to I site the
European model is in danger if we
obliterate the principle of personal
responsibility I close the
quote
therefore dear
colleagues it is our share
responsibility to do the best for all
our
citizens we
have a special
responsibility towards our youth the
future Generations are looking towards
us with hope and optimism in times of
geopolitical volatility and
socioeconomic
distress the future of Europe is about
the capacity of the Union
to give them honest answers and to
deliver in Education Health Prosperity
climate security and employment
opportunities 5 years ago we adopted the
CBU
declaration the 10 commitments made back
then are still valid
Unity
solidarity
cohesion the rule of law they continue
to lie at the very core of our joint
European
action for my part I remain deeply
faithful to these valuable values and
principles in my future
endeavors and I'm convinced
that these are the basis for the work
done by you here in the European
Parliament as well I also believe that
together we are able to maintain the
Union on the path of
success staying true to our vision of a
United and stronger
Europe thank
you
[Applause]
much president as you can see the
colleagues have very much appreciated um
your speaking points and your speech I
start by now by giving the floor to
president of the EP group Manfred
B Madam president commissioner Mr
President good to have you in the
European Parliament welcome and I want
to start with a quote we cannot ignore
the challenges we face on the Eastern
flank security and defense are
fundamental components of Union's Future
these Mr President are words uh from you
in the Munich security conference in
2019 I was in the audience and you were
right then and you are right now the war
in Ukraine has been a wakeup call for
many but not for you when you entered in
office in 2014 you said the defense was
one of the priorities for Romania and
for Europe in 2017 you managed to get
the Romanian Parliament to increase
defense spending to meet the NATO 2%
commitment and in 2023 Romania committed
to spend for defense
2.5% of its GDP it's your determination
that made Romania a strong pillar of
European Defense and one of Ukraine's
greatest Alli
this is leadership at its best not
speaking about problems but solving them
and dear president when we look at
Romania today we see a true European
success story since joining the European
Union in 2007 Romania has become country
Bucharest is number one in the Balkans
for building up startups kch is a true
European Tech Hub a country full of
talents that is fighting to turn brain
drain in brain gain Dear Mr
President great leaders are not only
great at National level but they are
also great on European level and you you
also REM remembered us uh that in the
CBU Summit in 2019 the first EU Summit
to be held on Europe's day you got all
leaders to agree on a Europe that
protects its citizens you have advanced
many EU defense initiatives always
working for a strong EU pillar in a
strong NATO you started many strategic
discussions on enlargement and it was
also your strong voice in the European
Council that made it possible to opening
the accession talks with Ukraine and
mova last December Europe owes a lot to
Romanian leadership and Romania owes a
lot to your leadership you showed to
Romanian citizens that a modern a
pro-european Romania is possible and is
successful and I want to also thank the
Romanian commissioner adalian and all
Romanian colleagues in the plenary who
served also to this broader perspective
and dear president for us as EP there is
also no doubt that it's now also time
that Romania must fully join the shenen
area you have been ready for 13 years on
this
subject if play dear friends and
ships are Crossing Borders without
inspection why should cars and trucks
have to wait in Endless lines Romania
and Bulgaria must me in shenen it's good
for the security it's good for the
business and it's good for our
citizens in the middle of the brexit
crisis in
2019 the spirit of CBU was fresh air to
relaunch Europe now 5 years later if I
may say this from an EP point of view
the EP family will go to Bucharest for
the Congress we go to Romania to kick
off our campaign and to kick off the
campaign for the European elections and
once again Romania is the place to shape
a safer home for all Europeans thanks
for your
leadership thank you Mr
Weber now on behalf of the snd group one
lope
a
gra thank you uh president metsola
president Johannes having listened to
what you've said I'd just like to share
two very positive messages that you gave
to us first of all I'm quite sure that
you know just how many of us in the
European Parliament very much celebrate
that for the first time under the
Spanish presidency at the end of
December we've been able to lift the
restriction
for your full enjoyment of the shenen
area uh for Romania and Bulgaria or for
both air borders and Maritime borders
this was a historic
resolution we know that the whole
process started in 2011 when the
commission decided that both process uh
both Romania and Bulgaria had overcome
the various uh requirements so we're
very happy that you are now able to
enjoy the uh shenen area we know that
when it comes to European
solidarity um especially in the area of
displaced persons from as a result of
Russian aggression in Ukraine uh we know
that there are thousands hundreds of
thousands of vulnerable women and
children that have come into Europe
across the border with Romania 200,000
are still in Romania being able to enjoy
these temporary protection uh orders
they're able to live freely and work and
be educated and obviously the rights to
education and to health cover so I'd
like to express my recognition to the
solidarity this very uh positive
solidarity and then only yesterday the
European Parliament validated 1,000 uh
1.5 billion Euro for the uh solidarity
fund for the 1.5 billion Euro to support
immigration which obvious viously is a
strengthening and uh the enhancing of
the rights of those people who have
entered the European Union looking for
protection thank
[Applause]
you the next speaker is the president of
the renew group Valerie a thank you
president Mr President commissioner dear
colleagues Romania is starting an
electoral cycle the presidential local
as well as the EP elections these are
are going to be crucial elections and it
is a strong signal for the building of
the future of Romania in Europe and
domestically in just a few months we
know that Romania is fully rooted in the
EU and fighting
corruption we have had a Resolute uh
commitment to the European public Pro
Prosecutors office and that has been
enormous in what has taken place in
Bucharest these values are the very
basic of our European Community our
family renew will fight to the end for
these uh projects to make sure that they
are brought to a fresh and now we have
an era in interference in our
territories and we're going to have to
be robust in our response cyber
protection fighting disinformation are
huge
challenges we know that the hard right
is trying to seow hate in Romania and
elsewhere therefore we will have a big
challenge to protect democracy and our
institutions Mr President now we have a
community of Destiny and I am so pleased
therefore to see the lifting of the air
andca borders and uh in Romania and
Bulgaria next month and before this
chamber I would like to state that our
political group will continue to defend
to the lifting the land border checks as
well that is a priority for us so our
community of Destiny is a strong
commitment also to the people in Ukraine
their struggle is ours and what they are
doing is our fight too and Romania has
been supporting Ukraine full on the
security of our continent is under
threat and it is together that we must
act I should like also to turn to mdova
for a second I am so
pleased that we have seen that the
country is strengthening its path toward
our Union Mr President this is a huge
year
not just for Romania but for all of
Europe in this election cycle our
institutions are at stake it is our
responsibility of all to protect them on
behalf of the green group Nikolai
[Applause]
Stefan president Minister commissioner
Madam President we speak today about the
future of Europe and the future of
Romania and we all wish for peace
freedom
equality but today's reality is
different so many Romanians continue to
leave the country we need new hospitals
our population is poor millions of young
people don't know what to expect from
the future in order for populism and
extremism not to grow as you have said
democracy must go hand in hand with
wealth Romanians and bulgarians are
still queuing at the borders they want
to become part of the shenen area in a
dignified manner this year president I
want to thank you for your engagement
towards Ukraine and for your Euro
Atlantic um position this is the right
way but your mandate and also our
mandates are coming to an end so let us
ask what kind of Romania do we leave
behind what Europe do we leave to our
young
people what did we want to do in CBU
this is also my
city let's put the future of young
people in the mid in the center of our
politics they need to be listened to
they need to be heard they need help I
want us to fight for a Romania which
gives young people accessible affordable
housing good jobs um good Services we
need housing for students our future
doctors professors architects
are they live in poor housing conditions
while they are studying the future
president of Romania
president maybe is in one such student
dorm today how do we treat them what do
we offer to
them let us also take care of our
environment I know you care for the
environment I also care a lot such as
the whole family of greens we need a
Greener Romania with clean cities with
fast rains with healthy food with more
respect for nature for soil for bees for
Animals I would like to leave to my
young daughter who is four today such a
country and such a continent and young
people and this is very important do not
want to live in a country in which the
extreme right is governing this is why I
ask you president do not allow Romania
to have a fascist government we did not
need a new ref referendum of hate
Europe leaves loves the human rights and
the human right to love whoever you wish
to and Romania must ensure that it will
not allow the Agents of Russia to uh
create policy for Romanians Emil Chan
said the past of Romania is not
flattering I'm not proud of the fact
that my ancestors have slept for so long
Waiting For Freedom today we are free we
do not wait for freedom but we will not
give in to extremists we have what we
need we have resources we have our heart
our heartbeats for Romania and for
Europe thank
you on behalf of the ECR group to
Christian
teres Madam president Madam commissioner
Mr President dear colleagues ladies and
gentlemen this is Europe debates held in
the European Parliament are a great
opportunity for European political
leaders to express their Vision about
the current and future course of Europe
I congratulate therefore the Romanian
president Claus johanes for sharing his
vision about Europe and emphasizing the
importance of Romania for the European
project but since the emphasizing the
project but since the debate it's about
Europe before we talk about what Europe
is it is imper ative to look back and
see what Europe was how this project
started where it is heading and if this
new Direction has anything in common
with the initial project when Madame V
liion held her speech in this planer in
2019 she said that the European project
is based on I quote on the Romanian law
on the Roman law and the Greek
philosophy end quote she forgot one and
the most important pillar of the
European project the judeo-christian
values civilization and culture it was
the Christian belief and the
judeo-christian values based on the
Bible that gave the power and the
motivation to many political leaders
from different European nations which
killed destroy and destimated each other
during the second world war to meet
after the war pray together forgive and
reconcile with each other and come up
with an economical and political
political plan that would and brought
people peace through
Prosperity because of these Visionary
faithful and courageous political
leaders the Western Europe was able to
achieve peace and hold it for over 80
years which was unprecedented for Europe
I say Western Europe because Us in the
Eastern Europe we were under the Soviet
occupation and we experienced a
different kind of political and
economical system an atheistic one which
the state and where the state and the
Communist party was God where the state
was above all and people were deprived
of their basic fundamental rights the
difference between the two political and
economical systems that Europe
experienced after the second world war
the European project that we witness
here which evolved in the European
community and Union in Western Europe
and the USSR and the Soviet Marxist and
communist model in Eastern Europe it's
exactly the pillar that was
intentionally or not forgotten by Madam
Ula V liion the judeo Christan values
culture and civilization the
judeo-christian values are the source of
and Notions that later evolved and were
mentioned in international treaty
National constitutions and laws like
human dignity equality before the law
separation of powers in the state or in
anable fundamental human rights Robert
Schuman a founding father of the
European project and former president of
the European Parliament said and I quote
democracy owns its existence to
Christianity Christianity teaches
equality of all nature of all men
Children of the same God Redeemed by the
same Christ without discrimination of
race color class or profession democracy
will be Christian or he won't exist an
unchristian democracy is a culture which
sinks into tyranny or Anarchy it was
exactly these judeo-christian values
that brought peace prosperity respect
among Nation nations in Western Europe
and the lack of them that brought
tyranny abuse and poverty in the USSR in
Eastern Europe it was this faiting God
that my fellow Romanians held strong
under communism and motivated them to
dream and Fight For Freedom it is
therefore uncomprehensible for many
fellow Romanians why in the past four
years exactly this personal and National
freedoms are violated by the European
commission under urula wonder liion the
European project was was built on a free
market principle which was brought which
has brought prosperity in Western Europe
in the past four years under the current
European commission we see that free
market principles are becoming an over
regulated one which is making the
European businesses and products less
likely to be competitive on the global
market the European project was built on
the concept that fundamental human
rights are inalienable and the
governments must not must not force or
impose medical products into CI bodies
but allow them to decide based on their
free and informed consent we saw what
happened during the pandemic when people
were forced to be vaccinated with
medical products that we find out now
later on have many adverse effects
Europe has long been a reference of
democracy and human rights championing
principles of Liberty equality and rule
of law any erosion of these fundamental
rights even by EU entities represents a
betrayal of our shared values and must
be met with firm opposition the Romanian
nation which I most proudly represent
thank you was able to overcome any
challenges during history and become
today one of the fastest growing
economies in Europe we did it through
faith and Fight For Freedom thank you ID
group gunar Beck two and a half minutes
thank you president commissioner your
Excellency Romania's motor insurance
industry has been in turmoil in recent
years 12 companies providing motor
insurance have been driven out of
business in just 12
years 12 Insurance fails in 12 years
should raise serious concerns about the
regulatory environment in the member
state in 2019 the Romanian Insurance
regulator ASF asked Euro in Romania to
buy the then failing City Insurance just
three years later ASF suspended Euro
in's insurance license in Romania
apparently for questionable reasons this
was Romania's last motor insurer
gone last year the European Bank of
reconstruction and development raised
questions with the Romanian Finance
Minister about the actions of ASF and
submitted a resolution proposal to your
predecessor to no effect the European
Insurance Watchdog iopa wrote a report
about the euro in safare in a reply to
my written question the European
commission claims it never saw the
report to date I'm denied access to the
full details of the iopa
report what are ASF and iopa trying to
hide from the European commission and
members of the European Parliament one
observ following the decision to strip
eurin of its license ASF awarded a
license to ai ai gurari a subsidiary of
of superbet and who's the chairman of
superbet one of commission presidenta
feline's Brothers your Excellency
Romania is one of the largest net
recipients of EU money you're receiving
10 billion EUR from the European budget
and the Next Generation EU fund
according to the corruption perception
index of Transparency International
you're the second most corrupt country
in the European Union now none of this
is ideal for a country hoping to attract
foreign
investors what I'm asking are you
proposing to do about it thank you I
give the floor now to CLA Daly on behalf
of the left
group
thank you president and president I
listen very carefully to your opening
remarks and for me I think Romania is
one of the most interesting European
countries I think the Romanian people
are pretty much like the Irish people in
my experience in terms of their approach
to life and I spent a month in timara
and Bucharest in the spring of 1990 as a
student leader from Ireland and learned
so much about the hopes and aspirations
of Romanian citizens in the post chesco
years and I think against that backdrop
for me it's quite unfortunate to see
that since joining the EU so many
Romanian people have been forced to
leave the country or being hoovered up
by Western Europe as a sort of pool of
cheap labor rather than having the
opportunities that they should have had
at home I'm sorry to see that you ended
up joining NATO and that you're spending
so much of your defense spend money uh
on things that really should be spent on
making people's lives better and I am
sorry to see cases such as the one
highlighted by my colleague about the
very very serious problems and questions
that remain to be answered regarding the
operation of the Romanian regulator the
ASF because of the consequential impact
not just on your own uh drivers but also
across the EU motor insurance sector and
I too and one of the members of this
house who for many months now have been
raising questions about that regulator's
decision to withdraw the license to Euro
ins Romania which is obviously part of
the largest Independent Insurance Group
in central eastern and Southeastern
Europe now I know you know about that
case Mr President and not just because
my colleague raised it but it is beyond
curious that the Romanian regulator
acted against this company three years
after requesting them to take over City
Insurance why did they do this it is a
fact that both the Bulgarian Financial
regulator and the European bank for
reconstruction and development queried
what your regulator was up to both of
them approached the European authorities
one of the organizations produced a
report cautioning against the
consequences of this they even produced
a resolution proposal which would have
mitigated at the impacts but nothing
happened and your country faces exposure
to a 500 million euro lawsuit at not to
mention the broader impact Beyond so I
suppose having brought this to the
attention of the European insurance and
occupation pensions Authority who are
supposed to mitigate these um issues but
who have failed to produce the report
for members of this Parliament it's
being withheld from us I'm deeply
concerned about the security it around
this case so I suppose my question Mr
President is really quite a simple one
in the interests of the citizens of
Romania and Beyond would you join us in
supporting our call to the European
commission to initiate a comprehensive
and independent review of this case I
give the floor now to Yan Rish bdan one
and a half
minutes Mr President
Madam president your
Excellency your
excellencies I have had the privilege to
listen to the analysis and vision of a
real Statesman Claus Johan is a
president of Romania of the last nine
years voted twice twice in office by
over 7 million Romanians this man has a
vocation for the European construction
it's not just a speech this is Romania
dear colleagues the most important
country to secure cure to to give us
Security on the Black Sea and we have a
huge border with Ukraine over 7 million
ukrainians have taken shelter in Romania
fleeing War over the past two years and
and Romania never closed their borders
were never hostile towards those who
were trying to save their lives and the
lives of their children on the contrary
on an Institutional level led by
President johanis and on a personal
level each and every person open their
hearts and open their homes to refugees
we're not the richest in Europe we're
not the ones that receive the most help
but we uh are the most hospitable
perhaps and this is Romania this is
Romania an honest country we um uh have
we are under attack uh by uh this uh um
Russian dictatorship who hates democracy
we we are um under Cyber attack and uh
he's trying to corrupt voters and to
destabilize uh Romania and its European
path is trying uh to to uh to destroy
our values but Romanians will stay
European president johanes will uh fight
until the last de is term in office to
make sure that things Remain the way
they are we have a huge uh energy
potential and the investment and the
investment in this country will uh make
the Europe's uh Energy Efficiency hang
in the balance and we are a rational
State Pro profoundly pro-european and
like other countries to follow our
league we have uh a president that
managed to uh to promote the uh his
country's interest without jeopardizing
the interest of the region um and the
and in Romania there's a song that was
sung first 150 years ago uh and this in
this song H it says if the one person is
alone uh we are alone but if we have two
people then we're United and in this
Hard Times uh this could be our Moto
this could be the the um anthem of
Europe right now
hor Maria graini next one
minute one minute one minute it will
start president dear
Roberta president
Minister first of all I want to thank
you for describing my country in such a
beautiful Manner and it is true and dear
colleagues the ones who tried to defate
Romania I want you to try to understand
it to visit it and talk to Romanians and
then you will understand I want to be
objective I want to speak about the
issues that we have raised in front of
all uh heads of state I want to ask you
do you really like the way Europe looks
what Europe's Europe looks like right
now do you think we could have done more
do we really have social cohesion um I
am in the um inco committee and I refuse
to say single Market which you have said
just as commissioner Bruton because I
believe we do not have a single market
yet and this is what we must fight for I
am finishing my second mandate and I am
quite disappointed because we do not
have a single market and Romania is not
in the shenen area and then do you think
it is fair that the
capap is the capap fair why do we not
have fairness for such a long time we
have so many farmers in Europe who are
protesting why are they not rewarded in
the same manner throughout Europe I
think these are problems that could have
been solved and in these years and even
even as we finish our mandates we must
continue our efforts because we know in
the council is the council is where
decisions are taken I thank you and I
congratulate you two
minutes de president
Mr President uh election year 2024 is
crucial for Europe because the values on
which it was built and have worked so
far are under siege from extremism and
European feelings and disinformation
this is why in order to keep democracy
alive this year's debates need to be
relevant for Citizens daily lives and
not so much so for the survival of
political parties of some political
leaders for Romania the challenge is
even greater we have all of our
elections this year happening this year
this can lead to a um complete reset of
the political establishment in Romania
and uh although we have uh U made slow
steps on the European um path Romania is
now uh a an Eastern Pon of the Europe
and thanks to our society and Mr
President you are the last political
actor to step out uh after the elections
this year without anything at stake
until then you have a duty to uh
communicate to our citizens how
important it is for us to belong to the
European family this is a complicated
year with a lot of um populist
challenges and I think you can do this
in a credible way and clear way Romania
and the European Union cannot slip uh
into extremism without Solutions and all
this election um pressure um makes us uh
wonder what kind of leader our citizens
our Romanian citizens and European
citizens expect today because after many
disappointments Romanians um feel that
the leaders are disconnected from them
they don't uh talk to them in simple
clear ways even when they do talk to
them and the effort to build Bridges
again in our uh crisis hit Society uh is
going to be huge and but what is at
stake here for us and for the Union he's
also huge of farmers uh a youth without
a future um citizens that have been
forgotten in small uh towns need to find
their motivation again and to be uh
committed for a with a vision for the
future where Brussels and Strasburg are
on their side and not their enemies in
their imagination grunenberg 1
minute this is Europe that is Europa
this is Europe yes yes well we have no
choice other than to work together for
climate St stability and biodiversity
dear colleagues and we need Romania and
its treasury of or veritable treasure
chest of um a primal Forest so thank you
very much president for protecting these
forests I myself have been to the fash
mountains and other beautiful places in
Romania and uh I've seen the beauty of
your unique forests and there are so
many
endemic species of Flora and FAA that
I've seen but I've also seen Progressive
uh cutting down of forests the clearing
of woods and forests in nura 2000 areas
and uh degradation of soil and erosion
of uh soil because there are no roots
holding it together we know that um
procedia has been uh initiated against
Romanian there were Promises of um
measures but this issue of tree felling
is not on the agenda so president
Johannes how are you making progress
when it comes to reform of the forestry
sector uh putting an end to uh clear
felling uh training uh young people to
work in the forest we need your help Bon
Frisco two
minutes thank you
chair Madam commissioner
president johanes sir in
March you
will guide Romania into shenen it's a
historic moment and it will make your
country and the European Union stronger
and I would like to state that Italy and
Romania will also be strengthening their
historic economic social economic and
cultural links that are based on the
jido Christian
values there are more than a million
Romanians living in Italy and 19 uh,
Italian companies exist in Romania we
are growing together we are also linked
via NATO SE Guardian in the defense of
the Mediterranean and in shenen it gives
a strength to our uh Union in political
and judicial cooperation in fighting
criminal organizations giving security
to the EU and our allies as Romania very
generously welcomed Ukrainian refugees
I'd also like to welcome this
possibility to speak to you sir to draw
attention to perhaps a minor issue but
link to the illegal trafficking of
animals and mistreatment one of the
major funding sources for international
CRI criminal organizations we must fight
together within our history and our
friendship that we have seen and to have
the most authentic uh demonstration of
Europe via fighting this thank
you president Mr President Madame
commissioner he he Mueller once wrote
in this country we had to walk eat sleep
and Love In Fear when we read about life
in communist times we can only
appreciate Romanian success in the
European project actually Romanian
culture and Heritage is indispensable
for Europe because it merges the Roman
Latin culture with the Orthodox Heritage
and with Germanic SL Avan and maral
influence and that gives Romanians a
unique ability to understand European
diversity we have seen Romania's amazing
Economic Development under your
presidency and impressive progress in
the rule of law today when we see
attacks on the rule of law in Spain in
malt in Slovakia we have to congratulate
you Mr President for your exemplary
leadership
and we have an historic step in the
lifting of air and Sea border controls
but that is not enough Romania Romania
like Bulgaria must fully join shenen you
dealt with the migration crisis pandemic
restrictions and the arrival of War
refugees in an extraordinary manner
under immense pressure the EP has always
been on your side in this matter
as the great Romanian poet
mies once
wrote time goes by time comes along the
time for complete and full assession to
sh thank you Mr
R next vice president Angel 1
minute
president Johannes it's an honor great
honor to have you here in the house of
European democracy here and of course we
welcome the Romanian citizens soon in
the shenen area so that they can cross
borders of on sea and land without any
controls we're very disappointed in the
Socialist and Democrats that these land
borders
are uh maybe disappearing but there are
still problems with the environment
there's a lot of destruction of the
environment and also a lot of goods that
are meant to be going to and from uh
Ukraine have remained blocked and so we
insist that the borders be opened up we
insist that Council does something about
this because Romania deserves this uh
roundly we want to continue to
strengthen our European project by doing
this President we're facing huge
challenges
the digitization of our societies for
example and briefly recently I had an
opportunity to attend an event organized
by Mr negrescu our colleague on digital
competence in the rural areas and at
this conference I heard about a lot of
very interesting um experiences and
projects in Romania I'd like to see how
you see the challenge of digital
transformation in Europe and what sort
of ideas you can give us to succeed
should we continue to regulate or should
we leave this up to the Techno Giants
and Ang
algorithms BOS 2
minutes thank you Madame presidenta dear
Madame
commissioner Madame Minister Mr
President uh I am honored uh that the
president of
Romania U is giving a speech before the
European Parliament in Strasburg Romania
and neighbors Ukraine and the Republic
of mova were Russ
keeps uh trying to exer its INF we are a
Black Sea uh country where the war is
affecting all the countries in the area
this is why it's Paramount that Romania
stay a
democracy built on European values this
is
Europe This is a topic at hand and
Romania is part of the EU has been part
of the EU for 17 years and we see uh how
Romania is developing is becoming more
modern and the 90 billion euros from
European funding have helped this
tremendously but also the fact that
Romanian citizens uh have access to the
European culture and life even though
we're not still fully uh fully fledged
members of shenen and we need to step on
it here and I'm very glad that you have
said it in no uncertain terms here in
the plenary Romania has shown that it
has the European values in its DNA that
is promoting these values even when
Romanian politicians have taken wrong
have made wrong decisions the citizens
uh have been staun Protectors of the of
democracy and the rule of law and
European values Romania is the rule of
law and this uh is very important for
the lives of each and every citizen we
all have a set of rules and no one no
matter how high uh the the position uh
is above these rules and speaking of
rules uh rules are the rules even in a
election year and the trust that EU
citizens have in EU in the EU
institutions will grow if we manage to
talk to our citizens in an open way and
explain to them step by step not only
what they can do for Europe but what the
what Europe is doing for them on a daily
basis and we won't be able to do this uh
if the debate in Europe in in Romania is
going to be skewed one
minute
thank you president and thank you
president Johannes for sharing your
perspectives on our common European
future very often this house is used for
National debates even from Prime
Ministers and presidents so I'm very
thankful that you shared your vision for
what Europe should look like so let me
ask you quite concretely when do you
think can we have an improved decision-
making in the council when will we move
to qualified majority when can we
actually change the treaties I would
love to hear an answer on that and then
second we have a great moment of
European democracy coming up with the
European elections but looking at the
different countries and also at Romania
I do see inhibiting factors to democracy
such as the amount of signatures you
need to collect to be able to run as a
party such as the fact that you can I
think only be or you have to be 23 to be
able to be a candidate these are all
things that could potentially slow down
our Democratic participation so maybe a
last question on this will you advance
the European electoral Law act that we
proposed here in 2020 with a second vote
for transnational list to strengthen our
European democracy thank you very much
thank you Mr Baga next Spen Simon one
minute for president Madame President
president
Johannes you are a president who in his
own country is always pushed for
reforms you stand by the rule of law
your fight against corruption is
exemplary and it is a great deal up to
you that Romania will be part of the
shenan agreement this strength of
reforms ladies and gentlemen is
something that we now need at European
level the European Union was founded to
protect Europeans from each other and
now we need to further develop it to
protect Europeans against the rest of
the
world the European Parliament has pushed
for proposal for reform to make the
European Union more able to act in the
future the council is having
difficulties coming up with an answer to
reach a decision on a convention you
president mentioned that there's a lot
that we could change without changing
the
treaties but if we really want to
overcome the internal opposition and
improve our action outside the European
union we need a European convention and
I'd call for your support for the
convention of that
convention one minute
[Applause]
M
mask thank
you in order to tackle Global challenges
we must first tackle our own challenges
at
home we are faced with global crisis and
challenges but we seem to have forgotten
the people who are next to us we have
lost the contact with those who we
represent
here the dissatis isfaction of Romanians
is growing and it is related to daily
life we see the protests of farmers and
people in the transport sector but the
truth is that we are all affected by the
crisis President we could have done more
for
Romanians honorable commission honorable
Council you have often ignored the
problems of my
people and I have seen too many
colleagues who were not able to say no
when our interests were were thrashed I
am going to repeat what I have always
said I believe we must reconnect to the
problems of ordinary people in our own
countries in our own cities I think this
is the only manner that we will be able
to increase their confidence that what
we do here is for their own good this is
the only way that Yash and Romania will
be in good hands just like like the
whole of
Europe thank you thank you
[Music]
pres every European citizens understands
what I've just said in Hungarian not uh
uh because the majority is now learning
the uh language of the minority but in
2020 you use the Hungarian language as a
political weapon against your opponents
ever since you've come uh to office you
haven't answered the plea uh of the
Hungarian minority to have uh an
agreement reach an agreement with a
minority and there the other countries
are doing it but there are issues that
are Taboo in Bucharest and the extreme
right is gaining ground in Romania uh
xenophobia and uh anti-democratic
feelings and anti-european feelings uh
are gaining ground and they um uh come
from the same parent and there's lots to
be done in Romania in Romania still and
and in the EU for Romania we are are on
a path of full integration in the EU
this is why we need to become full
members of the shenen area because this
is the right that we have earned
minute president johanes Romania is an
important European country it exceeded
to the EU in 2007 and in March will
enter shenen this is excellent news
because it means that we have a more
united and stronger Europe in which
citizens can have the same rights Europe
has many challenges to face together
here in this European Parliament in the
course of recent months we had the first
law on AI the first one in the world
that is not enough when we look at
migration for example Europe needs to
speak with one voice no nationalistic
vetos we must be structural in our
approach and not in an emergency
approach for those who arrive from the
Mediterranean and the Balkans digital
Revolution climate action new changes to
work fighting inequality these are the
priorities of our platform the elections
are just around the corner and they are
going to be crucial for this continent
millions of young Europeans are asking
for a better future we must be able to
make sure that happens by making the
best possible choices thank you one and
a half
minutes thank you madam president
president johanes welcome back to the
European Parliament we very well
remember here your speech from 2018 when
you stood up for European values and
told us that unity and solidarity are
the solutions for Europe time has proven
you right we have seen that Europe stays
United it provides Solutions and helps
people in need we have seen you
defending European values and we have
seen you defending a European approach
to challenges that we are facing Romania
has chosen the pro-european path and we
have seen a European decade in Romania
under your leadership and for this we
say thank you today we are seeing today
that Romania believes in Europe and we
are also seeing that Europe believes in
Romania together we have managed over
recent years to create the biggest
package of economic support after the
pandemic you always advocated for strong
support for Ukraine you led the efforts
of supporting the Republic of Moldova
and you helped Europe understand that we
are only safe if our neighboring
countries are safe looking ahead our
common task is to defend Europe Europe
means security Europe means Prosperity
democracy rule of law and Europe means
stability as pro-europeans we shall
continue to provide Solutions and tell
people that extremism is no solution to
any of the difficulties and challenges
that we face as pro-europeans we have to
speak up to defend Europe and defend
European values this is what we stand
for as a clear majority of pro Europeans
here in the European Parliament this is
what we are ready to achieve in the next
years together with you thank you very
much thank you very much Mr mishan can I
please ask the colleagues to be quiet as
we finalize this debate with the
president of Romania Claus johanes
Dominic Ru Deva one minute
yes thank you very much uh president
medola and thank you also to president
Johannes for your words I would like to
congratulate you for your commitment to
European integration and for your
European spirit and I would also like to
thank you for having mentioned the
institutional dimension in your
presentation I think it's only quite
clear that if we have an enlarged Europe
and if we do start relaunching the
enlargement process in the European
Union we're going to have to make sure
that that is accompanied by a deepening
of the accompanying processes you have
referred to the fact that we should not
rule out a reform of the treaties which
is something I welcome as well but I
think we have to go a step further in
that direction you referred to the
pasarel Clauses it is true these could
be triggered because they are set out in
the Lisbon treaty to allow us to deal
with more issues uh by qualified
majority voting but for the past 14
years the council has not managed to do
this and I very much hope that we don't
have to wait yet another 14 years so
please support the European parliament's
proposal of Reform of the
treaties Madame President Madame
commissioner Mr President Bulgaria and
Romania fulfill all the requirements for
full shenen membership this has been
repeatedly confirmed here in this
plinary Hall nevertheless for political
reasons we are kept outside for more
than 10 years and this makes our
citizens
uh inferior category of uh Europe
Europeans who cannot enjoy the full
range of their
rights so a partial uh access is not
success Mr President what are the
specific uh actions you discuss with uh
Bulgaria to remove all the obstacles in
our
transport links the discrimination
against bulgarians Romanians cannot be
[Applause]
tolerated dear president thank you for
your presentation today our two
countries have similar histories not
just in Christian Orthodoxy but we had
dictatorships you had a totalitarian
country run by the Kremlin we had a
dictatorship run by the
Pentagon today we see clouds gathering
over
Europe we have your elections I would
like your wisdom and your experience
how do we convince the voter that the
solution is not the extreme populist but
more democracy that we need a new
contract for the citizen of Europe
that's what I would call it a contract
to complete the European project
something that most of the members here
and the farmers in the streets feel has
not been completed so it's our duty and
your wisdom perhaps in the answer to
help us come up with the proper
arguments to bring Europe of our dreams
thank you thank you very much much that
brings us to the time for Mr President
to respond to a variety of questions and
comments that have been made Mr
President you have the floor to conclude
this debate can I please ask you dear
colleagues to keep
quiet thank you Madame
President honorable members of the
European Parliament thank you very much
this is a privilege for me to speak to
you here in the center of European
democracy thank you for your very
positive
feedback I thank the speakers of the
political groups for their
positions and uh I appreciate very much
the positive and constructive approach
in all the views expressed here but let
me thank you specifically for one issue
most of all mentioned which is the
shenan
issue
Romania is a very
determined a very strong and a very
faithful member of the
union we really believe that the union
has to be
United strong secure prosperous to make
this happen we have to finish the
European integration of all the member
States including
Romania so let's hope that we make the
decisive step we have the first first
step in place it's a good sign and let's
continue um there have been then some
issues and um it I think you you agree
it would go too far if I answered each
and every question so let me just point
out a relatively small number of
issues and I think you expect me to be
honest on these things so I try to be
short and
honest when I ran for president in 2014
for the first
time I promised to the Romanians a
couple of things I I'm not a not a great
speaker and I I'm not excelling in
promises so I said I will keep
Romania firm on the European track on
theack transatlantic track I will see
about the economy as far as the
president can do this to bring more
Prosperity but one important issue which
was very dear to
me I promised to strengthen the rule of
law which I did we have less
corruption we have an in independent
Judiciary and this is
not what I say it's what the commission
says and what you said because you
accepted the commission's report on the
so-called
CVM and one important issue was not only
to have an independent
Judiciary a strong prosecution it was
also important to have independent r
Regulators well I hear that one
regulator had an issue with one business
and as everywhere in a democracy and the
rule of law people if they feel the
decision was not so good go before a
judge this is what
happened and the judges decided that the
decision was
correct this is what I understand if we
speak about the rule of
law everybody has the same right
everybody has the right to a fair
trial and everybody has to accept the
result
now many of you asked more or less
precisely what I believe should happen
in the European Union I stated a number
of issues in my uh opening
remarks but
if it comes to it what what should we do
with the Union to make it function
better where where where are the
problems where are the real problems
where are the
systemic problems and what can be
done well some systemic problems and
some important issues have been
discussed in this house on our streets
in the
marketplaces and in convenience this is
I think you just finished before I
arrived uh a discussion about the common
European agricultural policy that's an
issue we have a decision on this as of
2020 four years ago so obviously people
ask me and I ask
others
why did it take us four years and huge
European
protests to rethink some issues of the
common agricultural
policy maybe could have happened
faster we are talking about the
environment about climate change that's
all correct personally I'm very much
involved in these issues I
am really convinced that we have to find
clim fight climate change and I believe
that we have to protect our environment
and we can do it we proved it we proved
it in Romania and we have a good policy
in this respect but we have to do more
now we have the green deal
which is
super but let me tell
you if it is not
sustainable and if it does not lead to
economic
growth and if we do not take everybody
with us it will be a
failure
so breath
elections upcoming most of you are
probably running for new mandate that's
fine not me I'm finished end of this
year I finished my mandate and that's it
so I believe that three
things should be changed or should be
improved first our relationship with the
European citizens
my impression Maybe I'm Wrong Maybe I'm
Wrong is that if the citizens are here
we are here we are levitating a bit
High maybe we should
decrease and be closer to our citizens
because what we do is
correct but we lost almost lost our
ability to explain this is to our
people we are not really performing well
when it comes to communicate our very
good results we're doing a super job and
more and more Europeans believe the
union is failing well this is about
communication communication between the
voters and the politicians so this is
one issue where I believe we can and
should do more and better
second some of you asked about decision
making it's about the architecture of
the Union how do we make it better and
we have to improve it because if we take
in Ukraine mova and the Western Balkans
we will be a large
Union and this decision making
especially in crisis War pandemic and
energy crisis has to be correct
transparent but
fast
so I believe that we have to work on our
architecture some of it may be possible
to change without opening the treaties
but some issues have to be changed in
the treaties they are not
perfect since we have these treaties is
I hope you don't mind me telling you
years have passed we are different Union
and we work towards a different Union
and I hope very much you agree we work
towards a better Union so let's work on
this at least one issue and you will
know what I mentioned it is not
acceptable that one member is using a
veto to stop all of us helping others
so if we're not in a position
yet to
generalize a qualified majority voting
which may be defined different than it
is now not talking about the details but
at least we should have the courage to
say no veto and let's take it out of the
decision making process that's something
very concrete we should
do
finally our external image well I
believe we have to be much better here
first we have to integrate those who
want to be with us and those we want to
be with us Ukraine mova Western Balkans
they try to become parts of part of the
the union some of them for 20 years I
mean are we
serious are we do we want them if we do
let's go if not let's say them
no but dragging on you know very well
never makes things
better
and
somehow linked to this is how we act
towards others it's what we call foreign
policy well guess what we don't have one
this is strange isn't
it we have as many foreign policies as
we have member states and maybe even
more thanks you're
right maybe this is the reason
why
our foreign policy
weight is way way way smaller than our
economic weight and this is not good for
us because economic policy and foreign
policy have to go hand in hand so we
should work on these two extension and
foreign policy now the elections are
upcoming each of you is going to to
fight for a
seed or a principle or a
value that's correct every party comes
up with concepts with ideas with
policies you will accuse each other of
being well the wrong guys you will fight
for as many votes as possible that's
absolutely Fair that's the essence of
democracy campaigning profiling trying
to be the best please do so you sitting
here are the best this is why you sit
here but
please if you fight each other don't
fight
Europe if you
fight if you fight for
votes against your
opponents still fight for European
union and if you fight with the other
party and tell them they're not the
right guys please do not fight against
the European solidarity because without
this we are
doomed so no matter who is
winning and I hope the best
are winning let's uphold our values our
principles our unity and our solidarity
thank you very
much
for